all right this is a fox with huge week
for the presidents so much breaking news
we have all the angles new information
covered tonight first we have long
reported on this program going back to
2007
yeah journalism is dead and also that
the mainstream media mob is nothing more
than an arm of the extreme radical new
socialist Democratic Party they
coordinate a political message they
deliver it together in concert with one
another basically they're like one one
in the same they're an echo chamber they
repeat the same talking points remember
oh manufactured crisis they use the same
words tonight we have more proof a
journalist who writes for The Huffington
Post New York magazine his name is
Yasser Ali took to Twitter earlier today
to express his outrage at NBC News their
politics managing editor one by the name
of Daphna Linzer according to Ollie she
tried to intimidate him not on behalf of
NBC News no on behalf of the Democratic
Party now Allie wrote that quote that
misconduct during the call was highly
inappropriate it was unethical she
wanted the reporter to hold off on
publishing the dates of an upcoming
Democratic primary not to help NBC not
so her network could do it first but
that's so the DNC could inform state
party leaders
why is she advocating for them as I li
put a quote she was calling to bully me
into delaying the publication of an
innocuous scoop and at no point did she
ever advocate for her network it was
only about the DNC after reminded Allie
quote me that she was a national
security reporter at the Washington Post
for ten years and they would hold stuff
all the time
hold it you know hold it anyway how can
Comcast think about this they are the
powerful parent company of NBC News
allow this kind of corruption in its
ranks just like a whole News Channel
full of tinfoil hat conspiracy theories
I have an important question very
important question for everybody
watching at home tonight are you at all
shock that NBC News is working on behalf
of the DNC
how many times have I said since o7
journalism is dead and buried right now
their credibility frankly could never
get any worse after all the two plus
years breathlessly breathlessly pushing
the biggest hoax in American history
now fake news CNN and tinfoil hat
conspiracy TV MSNBC literally now shown
to be liars who are they lying to their
own viewers and as I pointed out every
second every minute every hour of every
24-hour day every week month year and
now their audience well they are leaving
in droves look at this the media bosses
bad people
[Applause]
the crooked journalists the totally
dishonest TV pundits and by the way they
know it's not true
they just got great ratings by the way
their ratings dropped through the floor
last night did you see
they had their audiences every single
day night on the edge of their seats
coming it's coming soon now it's
happening it's gonna happen it's
definitely happening at that
and the mother important well that ended
all of that and what you saw is the most
dramatic precipitous drop an audience
with tinfoil hat conspiracy TV MSNBC
fake new CNN hundreds of thousands of
viewers by the way CNN not even making a
million viewers a historic decline now
the media of course they wanted this
president to be guilty of treason
they wanted him to fail spectacularly
they still do and that's why they are
now demanding that the motor report be
released in full and that the summary
report from the Attorney General bar is
not to be trusted
but Barr announced he's gonna release
the whole thing anyway so why would he
live when he knows he's releasing it and
everyone's gonna see it pretty bizarre
what's this we don't have the malla
report we need it there they're covering
up at this point Jeff Sessions who but
one decent thing that he did was just
recuse himself this guy is not recused
it feels like the seeds of a cover-up
bar then I think stepped out intercepted
it put his own spin on it
and now he's sitting on it that you're
hiding behind Donald Trump's own Roy
Cohn William bar yeah I said it Donald
Trump's own Roy Cohn who squeezes
together a couple of Simmons fragments
and puts it in the letter while trying
to keep from the American people the
molar report they forgot to tell you
that they completely said no evidence of
collusion just like the FBI said just
like the house Intel said just like a
bipartisan Senate committee said it's
now the fourth time no evidence of
collusion but the media that hates Trump
with range the mob desperately want the
full Muller report release but they
never asked for the FISA applications
and the court or page be released bulk
of information as Hillary's bought and
paid for dossier they never talked about
that either real Russian interference in
an election after the
rigged an investigation into their
favored candidate because they thought
that she should win a hundred million a
zero and that we smelly Walmart voters
that are irredeemable deplorable z--
that cling to God guns Bibles and
religion you know we don't know what
we're doing
remember the gang of eight information
closed-door testimony that's all going
to be coming out it'll come cascading
down on them like the transcripts we
recently got from page struck and and
Christopher steel and McCain's aide they
don't want a full and fair Clinton email
investigation they don't care if there's
a dual system of justice no equal
justice under the law no equal
application of our laws we don't care if
they follow the Constitution
I don't want an investigation into this
rampant abuse of power at the highest
level of the DOJ and the FBI
none of the media you know just the all
they want is the Muller report so that
maybe they'll find a line and they'll
cling to that you know I like it's manna
from heaven because Attorney General bar
and rod Rosenstein pretty instantly
agreed no no evidence of any obstruction
for a crime that was never committed
anyway I have a spoiler alert as you
could probably tell new narrative is a
lie as pointed out last night right here
on this program by Rush Limbaugh take a
look so we're being led to believe that
this report does contain evidence of
collusion bars lying about it now if
this is so silly if it contains evidence
of collusion
then where is Muller on television all
nights and wait a minute wait a minute
that's not what my report says my report
has plenty of evidence of collusion I
had all these anti Hillary people on my
staff we found all kinds of evidence and
Maher is like why is it mother doing
that if Barr is lying about what's in
the report such a great point in
breaking today the Attorney General bar
Oh
like he said in his four-page letter
yeah last week he's gonna release the
mother report mid April if not sooner
and there are no plans to submit the
report to the White House for a
privileged review which by the way I
would think is a mistake
that's because apparently they know
there's nothing to hide
all the media lying all the speculation
you know what
once again dead wrong and by the way
Baro always said he intended to release
it so why would he send out words that
would be can't be contradicted when he
released it you know if it was that big
a deal
what would the problem be they would
never stop they would demand he be fired
bad news for the media great news for
the country they never report about the
successes of the president the records
that he's broken so without a doubt a
momentous week not only for the
president but also for this country
because you know what we came
dangerously close and are still dealing
with a significant serious abuse of
power attempted coups but for now and we
got to keep vigilant facts common sense
logic to have prevailed that's why I
keep saying we must get to the bottom of
all of this and hold them accountable
and we will on this show after facing
more than two years of non-stop constant
tinfoil hat conspiracy theories non-stop
media lies hysteria and on a 20-plus
month partisan which on presidents been
vindicated and that's killing them
should be great for the country the
president didn't do it but not for the
media not for the Democratic Party
because they're gonna lose their power
and they've lost their credibility after
three years of Lies and smears and
slander the Russia hoax is finally dead
they're wrong so often aren't they think
about this Cambridge police Ferguson
Baltimore think about they wouldn't vet
Obama they wouldn't tell you Obama's
failed record Trayvon Martin George
Zimmerman rushed the judgment no due
process Duke Lacrosse UVA they're wrong
all the time and it's sad look at what
they did it was 16 year old kid Nicholas
and man look at how they wanted to
believe Jesse small it's so bad
a team of partisan Hillary Clinton
loving Democrats found zero evidence of
Trump Russia collusion the fourth time
now we've had that
conclusion because there was no Trump
Russia collusion never was none zero and
there is no denying the absolute fact
the President Trump won the 2016
election fair and square because the
American people wanted the disrupter to
drain the swamp and he's doing it
despite a concerted effort by a powerful
few which is really scary that would
abuse the powerful tools of intelligence
who take him out
kind of soft coup in America all right
the question is how do we hold them
accountable where do we go from here the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in American history a witch hunt
spurred by illicit election interference
not from Russia but from the highest
levels of our own government not rank
and file a coordinated by corrupt
unelected bureaucrats inside the Obama
administration which does make us wonder
well now that we learned last week that
the Attorney General of Obama Loretta
Lynch you know who met on the tarmac
with Bill Clinton and said it's a matter
not an investigation that they were
courting a page instruct they were if
the fix was in
they knew the fix was in because there
was all Democrats working in the
attorney general's office and what did
Obama know now that it said in the
attorney general's office what did he
know when did he know it because
everybody must be held accountable we
cannot let this happen as Donald Trump
says the president says to any other
president according to Rush Limbaugh the
time to act is now he's right take a
look the objective remains to get Donald
Trump out of office either by driving
his numbers down or impeaching him or
defeating him in 2020 they aren't
through trying to get rid of Donald
Trump they're not through trying to
overturn the election results of 2016
they're never going to finish trying to
get rid of even if he's elected in 2020
they're setting up the impeachment now
with all of this stuff it's never that's
why these people need to be politically
defeated and pounded into the ground to
the point of view elements great point
to the point of irrelevance see we don't
hold them
countable this will happen again and
again and we'll lose the country it's
that serious
there's got to be a constitutional
republic all laws are based on our
Constitution we must demand equal
justice under the law equal app of
application of our laws be restored no
constitutional republic can survive
without it
for far too long we have seen one set of
standards for well-connected Democrats
and then there's the standard for the
rest of us yeah what would happen to you
or me or anybody if we deleted 33,000
subpoenaed emails and cleaned out our
hard drive with bleach pit and had an
aide bust up our devices with hammers
and pulled out the SIM cards look at
Chicago Jesse's smaller he was given a
free pass that state as Attorney General
Kim Fox declining to prosecute all
charges dropped despite overwhelming
evidence including two witnesses that
would testify that Smollett staged a
disgusting hate crime hoax and video of
them of buying the very things that were
used in that incident mayor of Chicago
I'm no fan of Rob dead fish Emanuel he
wants Smollett to repay the City of
Chicago for the cost of the
investigation well there's possible
federal charges but Emanuel also wants
you to know that it's not really Jesse
small its fault no President Trump if
the dog bites at the Beast things if
you're feeling sad of course its Trump's
fault
take a look look I've always said from
day one this is a trump free zone the
city of Chicago and I mean it let me be
really clear about something
the only reason Jessie small I thought
he could take advantage of a hoax about
a hate crime who's for the environment
the toxic environment that Donald Trump
created yep everything in the world is
Trump's fault you have a hangover it's
probably Trump's fault literally if
President Trump adopted the Democrats
insane new Green Deal agenda gave every
American five million dollars in cured
cancer they'd still hate him and by the
way apparently if Jesse Smollett hires
two people to dress up like Trump
supporters and shout racist things at
him while pretending to assault him all
President Trump now meanwhile what small
it
here has real serious consequences now
we did send our own Lawrence Jones to
Chicago to see what locals think about
what has been called a whitewash of
justice take a quick look the burdens
came out on the Justice Mullah case they
decided to drop the charges how do you
feel about robbed the answers are
revealing we have the full video coming
up on this program we will always fight
for justice due process and the
presumption of innocence inalienable
rights that made this the greatest
country man has ever known that God has
ever created
whether it's Jesse Smollett his case
Chicago the deep state abuse of power in
Washington and the swamp we will demand
accountability for those who stomp on
the rights of others at the end of the
day it's the future of our Republic
depends on life liberty equal justice
for all